she's extraordinary she really truly is
and even you know we did five years
together we worked five years there was
never a moment where I I wasn't just
like completely shocked or impressed by
her insane range you know and her man
you always pick up things from from
actors that you admire and one of the
things I picked up from her because she
had so much material she had these huge
speeches and monologues and stuff but
she would get these and she's like
dealing with kids you know at home and
this and that and they're young and
trying to memorize this stuff at three
in the morning and you know you know
crying the kid's crying she would get
there and you know and she would flub if
I mess up I try to muscle through it I
would see her flub and I'd do the and
I'd see her do the opposite and she
would just kind of do this thing where
she goes aha and she would turn into
Jello and I was like what is she doing
and then I was like oh my God if you
can't remember anything when you're
tight how could you possibly feel
anything when you're tight other than
tightness you're not going to be open to
anything and it's certainly not going to
help your memory to suddenly beat
yourself up because you forgot the line
and I was like I was like I'm stealing
that for sure I'm stealing that is
awesome